hello and welcome back to the omics
logic data science program
in this session we will review
classification and metrics we will
discuss feature selection
revisit some of the challenges and use
cases for feature selection
we'll review the content and assignments
moving forward
and discuss the generalized regression
models which are the main topic of today
first let's see what we have covered so
far in the previous sessions and
assignments we learned how to load
transform and visualize data we talked
about statistical evaluation of a data
set and analysis for hypothesis testing
we also spoke about performing
exploratory analysis of a data set and
understanding its structure
we talked about the link between
molecular features sample groups and how
to identify important trends in data and
had a discussion about various
clustering methods and ways to evaluate
their use for a given data set finally
we talked about classification and
feature selection briefly let's review
some of these topics to understand how
they are all connected to each other and
what were the major outcomes from each
one of these exercises
first let's talk about data mining
dimensionality reduction or embedding
and clustering
we briefly covered three different
methods pca which reduces dimensionality
of the full data set to preserve data
variants it uses euclidean distance
between samples based on all features
and is used to find such projections
that retain most distances found in the
original space
evaluating distances in the projection
have to include the explained variance
of each component
that way if pc1 is 40
and pc2 is 10
distance on the x-axis is four times
greater than the distance on the y-axis
the second method we talked about was
mds and nmds multi-dimensional scaling
and non-metric multi-dimensional scaling
so sometimes
we might be interested in a data set
that we suspect has a composition with
abstract measurements of diversity and
change between distinct groups of
samples the goal of nmds is to collapse
information from multiple dimensions
into just a few so that they can be
visualized and interpreted unlike many
other techniques that rely on euclidean
distances nmds uses rank orders which
show closer points related by their rank
in the respective group reading in mds
plots is simple objects that are
ordinated closer to one another are
likely to be more similar than those
further apart
but the scale of the axes is arbitrary
as is the orientation of the plot one
measure of nmds quality is a measurement
called stress
higher stress usually about 0.2 should
be interpreted with caution and stress
above 0.3 is highly suspect the next
method we talked about is t sne or t
distributed stochastic neighbor
embedding
which is a technique for dimensional
reduction that is especially good for
high dimensional data sets
with non-normal distribution for example
we used it for single cell data that is
zero inflated specifically it models
each high dimensional object by a two or
three dimensional point in such a way
that similar objects are modeled by
nearby points and dissimilar objects are
modeled by distant points with high
probability the distances refer to
perplexity which is a measure for
information that is defined as 2 to the
power of the shannon entropy perplexity
may be viewed as a knob that sets the
number of effective nearest neighbors
loosely speaking one could say that a
larger or a denser dataset requires a
larger perplexity
typical values for the perplexity range
between 5 and 50.
one of the challenges in such scaling is
that we don't intuitively understand
these distances and so we have to rely
on some rules of thumb when we know the
number of samples the numbers of
features and what our approximately data
looks like
one way that you can dig deeper into
these methods is to apply them to
various data sets so we provided you
with three different types of data gene
expression data for distinct types
associated with tumors in different
tissues
mutation frequency data from viral
genomes sampled from various
geographical locations across time
and a microbiome dataset with
operational taxonomic unit abundances
across several types of conditions using
your understanding of the methods that
we discussed like pca nmds t-sne and
umap you can see how dimensionality
reduction can make data interpretable
revealing patterns that you can build
upon in your final comparative analysis
importantly one takeaway was for you to
see the relationship between the number
of features
the number of objects the amount of
noise that the data has and the specific
types of labels that we can use to
understand the explanatory value of such
a dimensionality reduction what is
especially interesting to see after we
understand how dimensionality reduction
algorithms help us find patterns in data
and visually interpret them is to
further explore clustering as a way to
organize these patterns into distinct
groups or clusters
with so many algorithms for clustering
that exist developing a sense of how
these algorithms perform with various
data sets can help you select the right
methods for the task at hand and know
how to evaluate the results clustering
can be used in several different ways
helping us find meaningful patterns that
explain phenotypes or even uncover
hidden patterns that can lead to biased
interpretation
what's important is to always test our
assumptions working with the data and
trying to understand what might lead to
observed results that we get from the
analysis
scikit-learn has a collection of such
methods implemented in a standardized
and easy to use framework with
parameters and outputs that we can use
to understand how each one works and
what are the specific ways we can test
and measure the success of our
analytical approach this includes
methods to explore data structures find
optimal number of clusters explore inter
and intra cluster variation and evaluate
how well clusters match our expectations
if we have labeled data
importantly we can test the results
visually using dimensionality reduction
methods with two or three projections to
help us spawn unexpected variation
we can also use clustering to study the
features
or the objects that we have in our data
for example when we use clustering to
study features in our data we have to
transpose the data frame in our example
we can explore the gene expression
profiles to find closely related
patterns that differentiate between
genes responsible for various biological
functions
in this data frame
our rows are genes and columns are
samples we can transpose the data frame
and look at it in a different way we can
look at
samples being the rows and genes being
the columns
however since the number of genes we
have is much greater than the number of
samples
linear dimensionality reduction gives us
a somewhat meaningless picture that
explains a lot of data variants without
any distinct patterns
which means the patterns might be more
complex than expected with many smaller
groups of genes that are linked together
in such cases non-linear methods like
t-sne or u-map can be useful
non-metric embedding methods like t-sne
and u-map can be used for
high-dimensionality data together with
density clustering like db scan hdb scan
optics and spectral clustering to
identify closely related clusters of
genes that can have a biological
interpretation
here you see a visual of db scan after
dimensionality reduction with t-sne and
umap
importantly umap can provide us with
multiple projections while t-sne is
limited to just a few
knowing how to use different methods and
what are the limitations of some of the
clustering methods we can arrive at an
appropriate combination of
dimensionality reduction and clustering
to identify meaningful groups
in the exercises you should be able to
explore noisy and biologically
meaningful clusters of genes that would
lead to additional questions about the
datasets as you mine them
evaluating identified clusters in the
data can be biologically interpretable
like this cluster with high
inter-cluster correlation coefficient
that all maps directly to a single
biological function of ribosomal genes
we can again spot variation that can
influence clustering and reveal
important abnormalities like an outlier
sample or group of genes we can also
develop metrics to compare clusters to
each other to understand how gene sets
are related
in conclusion data offers a lot of
insights as we play with it and mine it
for patterns these patterns can be
revealing about the complex relationship
between objects and features in our data
insights can be technical or
interpretable in a biological way
most importantly these patterns are
important to study and understand using
appropriate methods settings and
evaluation metrics that we have learned
about so far now let's also review a
different set of methods that we covered
related to the task of classification
one way to think about our data is to
view it as a combination of noise and
signal which could be explained by a
model
a model of statistics can be a function
and a set of coefficients that follow
certain assumptions for example we have
a general understanding of probability
which we can apply to hypothesis testing
or we can learn to extrapolate what we
see in data with some measure of
confidence in machine learning
algorithms and statistical principles
can be extended further
a model in machine learning is the
output of a machine learning algorithm
run on a specific data set
a model represents what was learned by a
machine learning algorithm
the model is the actual thing that is
saved after running a machine learning
algorithm on training data and it
represents all of the different rules
numbers thresholds and any other
algorithm specific data structures
required to make predictions
once the model is trained it can become
a method that we rely on to deal with
new data or it can be studied to really
understand what's going on inside the
data set and why we find certain
patterns to train the model we have to
label the data by using phenotypic
information like cancer stage subtype or
risk factor
an algorithm learns this target mapping
function from training data
the learning can be summarized as a
learning of a function f that maps input
variables x to output variables y
assumptions about the data and possible
function that models relationships can
greatly simplify the learning process a
learning model that summarizes data with
a set of parameters of fixed size
independent of the number of training
examples is called a parametric model no
matter how much data you throw at a
parametric model it won't change its
mind about how many parameters it needs
non-parametric methods are good when you
have a lot of data and no prior
knowledge and when you don't want to
worry too much about choosing just the
right features in many cases advances in
computational technologies made many
non-parametric methods that were too
costly to train accessible to anyone on
sizable data sets decisions about
assigning a sample to one class or the
other follow a parametric or a
non-parametric approach svm and random
forest are both non-parametric
approaches that rely on data quantity
the output of a model can be evaluated
for accuracy precision recall and other
representations that we went over in
exercises
importantly we saw how for most
non-parametric methods training and test
data that accurately represent the
conditions we have plays a major role in
the quality of a model overall since
many data sets have some
over-representation for various classes
it is important to understand these
metrics in the context of each class for
example if the total number of samples
you have is 10 and one class is only two
samples then an 80 accuracy still is
pretty bad for that one class we can
also see how various non-parametric
models are affected by the number of
features one way we can do this is by
running a dimensionality reduction
method that can retain multiple
projections that are used for training
as we can see here umap already does a
great job at retaining the expected data
structure by maximizing distance between
subtypes of samples in our data set in
one of the exercises we reviewed the
number of umap projections has an impact
on the accuracy of classification for
various models support vector machines
performs best overall
that is because we never reach
a point where the number of projections
is greater than 30. random forest
achieves perfect accuracy at five
dimensions decreasing with more number
of dimensions that are being added
k n seems to perform better with higher
number of dimensions but does not
achieve good accuracy overall what are
some of the conclusions that we should
have about these classification models
non-parametric methods are affected by
data using training and test data sets
noise to signal ratio influences
classification quality for models in
different ways the number of features
and what these features represent
whether they represent noise or actual
signal like in umap or pca projections
is also critical for the quality of the
model reducing the number of dimensions
helps some classification models
dimensionality reduction helps us
understand model quality intuitively and
link it to a biologically meaningful
interpretation one of the useful ways to
study a parametric model is to
understand the relationship between
specific features and class predictions
of a model
in the exercises we reviewed you would
have seen many times how a
dimensionality reduction algorithm like
pca is applied to thousands of genes or
just a select few when thousands of
genes are present many of them could be
considered noise that actually prevents
accurate separation between known groups
so we might only spot the most
significant variance in data in the case
of the cell line data set we only see a
separation into two major groups that
are the most different from each other
classification that looks for separation
between defined classes will learn the
difference between classes based on
coefficients we can take the top feature
importance for models like svm or random
forest
performing pca on select features will
reduce noise thus increasing variance
explained by top principal components
the reduced data set of 15 genes has an
overall variance explained of almost 80
percent
compared to only about 30 for the full
data set these 15 genes were selected
based on a model output which assigns
accuracy and impurity measures to each
gene such measures can help select the
best features that can separate between
classes and optimize classification we
can also view pca loadings that show how
each gene profile contributes to
variance direction of each loading can
be used to understand the way such
feature contributes to separation
between labeled groups in our data the
random forest classification relies on
randomly selected portions of data and
many classification trees majority
voting helps select the optimal
decisions for classification the data
points that repeatedly show increased
accuracy and decreased impurity between
classes can be selected as the top
features that contribute to the model
accuracy overall in scikit-learn these
are termed feature importance based on
mean decrease in impurity and feature
importance based on feature permutation
support vectors are data points that are
closer to the hyperplane and influence
the position and orientation of the
hyperplane using these support vectors
we maximize the margin of the classifier
deleting the support vectors will change
the position of the hyperplane these are
the main points that help us build our
svm in linear svm the resulting
separating plane is the same space as
your input features therefore its
coefficients can be viewed as weights of
the inputs dimensions and we can use
these weights to select top features
that are responsible for model accuracy
now that we've completed this review let
us turn to another important topic for
machine learning parametric
classification and regression so let's
now speak about generalized linear
models
first
let's talk about linear regression
variables are terms we use to define our
data in an experiment
any externally controlled variable
related to data collection is called an
independent variable it is manipulated
by what we intend to study
the data we collect are the dependent
variables
these variables represent the
measurements we take of the conditions
in the experiment
oftentimes we would like to establish a
relationship between changes in
independent variable to establish the
relationship of measured dependent
variables with the cause we control
sometimes this cause can be indirect and
therefore not a causal effect even
though it appears to be so
nevertheless establishing a non-random
relationship between the two
is important
let's say we collect the data on eye
color
sex
age height and weight of people
we hypothesize that some variables here
are related and some are not we also
think there are exceptions to the rule
the age and height or weight are related
but maybe not always relationships
observed in data can show which
variables are related or unrelated and
if related then by how much for example
weight and height seem to be logically
related
are they in this data set if we plot a
trend line we will find that the trend
line goes up the bigger the height
weight is also increasing
but the dots are not too close to the
line some dots seem to be far away from
the line
is there a way to quantify this
relationship we found
to study the relationship we can use a
coefficient of correlation or r squared
this measure shows how well the data in
our data set is explained by the
correlation line drawn through this data
in this case we get an r squared
coefficient of 41
40 is okay but not perfect our
conclusion is that height and weight are
correlated but not perfectly
such relationships can be of several
types positive negative and non-linear
linear regression is a way to further
model such a relationship to determine a
mathematical function explaining the
relationship between a dependent and
independent variable in the data set
if there is a relationship such a
function is predictive and will inform
us how the independent variable will
change if we change the dependent
variable
the goal of regression analysis is to
find the right coefficients of this
formula that minimize predictive errors
based on the data that we have the
regression formula has both the
dependent and independent variables in a
mathematical equation plus a constant
intercept and a coefficient
the dependent variable is related
to the independent variable with
additional considerations a constant
intercept or where the line starts from
the slope of the regression line also
known as the coefficient
to get these variables from data we use
the least squares approach it helps
measure the distance from each dot to a
line finding the line that best fits the
data
simple linear regression is an approach
to model the relationship between a
dependent variable and one independent
variable the linear regression model
assumes a linear relationship between
the input and output variables
if this relationship is present we can
estimate the coefficients required by
the model to make predictions on new
data
same principles can be applied in anova
where variables are factors and factor
regression analysis factor regression
analysis is an example of multiple
linear regression that uses a linear
function to predict the value of a
dependent variable containing the
function for n independent variables
it can also be applied to multiple
independent variables the entire set of
data points can be evaluated for fit to
the regression function to use linear
regression we add another parameter
called e or epsilon which is normally
distributed and centered around the true
regression function
this is a random component which
represents the data fit or distance
between the data points to the
regression function by non-random or
structural components
as a result the fitted model can be used
for prediction of continuous or
categorical variables
for categorical variables we can use the
regression approach to model a
relationship between probability of
category for a given observation and the
continuous data we have
if we imagine having just one type of
variable for example bmi
we can use the label
of each observation some clinical
diagnosis for an individual and data x
in our case bmi to model a relationship
between these two variables using a
distribution of samples around two
centers let's call them n for normal and
d for diabetes a gaussian curve of
probable distribution for the given set
of data has to be modeled using an
assumed distribution
its center on the axis and the sigma or
how wide it is
in statistics maximum likelihood
estimation is a method of estimating the
parameters of an assumed probability
distribution given some observed data
we have to determine the distribution
curve of probability for samples with
each label or find the sigma and center
for each gaussian curve
for linear regression we can use the
least squares methods to determine the
most fitted linear regression function
for the model parameters or find the
separation point where the relationship
between probabilities is equal to one
for example if the group of people in a
data set with low bmi is less likely to
have diabetes and the group of people
with high bmi is more likely to have
diabetes we can calculate probability
for each group to have patients with
diabetes and learn the relationship
between bmi and diabetes in terms of
probability
using such a model we can predict which
class any new observation belongs to
quality of our prediction will be
determined by the fit of our model to
data
that is where we need to be mindful of
the assumptions in our parametric model
the probability curve is a sigmoid that
can be modeled by a logistic function
the curve can be used to make a decision
about any data point we might want to do
prediction on the same can be done for
more than one variable for example with
for example with x1 as bmi and x2 as
blood glucose
same as with one variable we will now
have to estimate a probability curve
based on some distribution where the
gaussian multivariate distribution is
used using the same set of linear
equations we can now fit the model to
our data
for any new points we use the data
coefficients to identify the most likely
class it belongs to given data x1 or its
bmi and x2 or its blood glucose this
model for probability is called logistic
regression which is a statistical method
that can also be termed machine learning
in its algorithmic form the goal is to
model the probability of a random
variable y y being 1 or 0 given
experimental data regression modeled
using the logistic function can be
transformed to linear regression to a
logarithm on both sides of the equation
which is also called log transformation
how do we actually make a decision for a
test instance x we say yes if the
probability is more than 0.5 and no if
it is otherwise we call 0.5 the decision
boundary
in scikit-learn logistic regression is a
part of the linear model library that is
because logistic regression uses a
linear function where function
coefficients have a linear relationship
to use the model we need to specify
whether we have a binary problem or a
multi-class problem where we can use one
versus the rest scheme or the
multinomial scheme where multinomial
refers to multi-class we can also
specify the solver for this model for
example lbfgs stands for limited memory
bfgs the breydon fletcher goldfarb
channel algorithm
the solver
is an algorithm to find the optimal fit
in this case applied to gradient descent
gradient descent is a numerical
approximation of the ordinary least
square solution
ordinary least squares is the analytical
solution for a linear regression problem
which finds the least value of squares
of the air
applying this to linear regression is
fairly easy because of found
coefficients and linear equations
gradient descent is an alternative to
the oles solution by iterative method
the basic idea of gradient descent is to
find such a portion of the error curve
using a step which can help us find the
minimum value assuming that the curve is
non-linear for each step where step size
can be set by the user we can
approximate the curve as a straight line
and calculate the descent in weight
until we reach the global optimum for
this approximation
such a solution to maximize fit or
minimize errors in fit for our data can
be applied to generalized linear models
and even non-linear classifiers like
support vector machines
generalized linear models are called
generalized because they assume a
distribution as the basis of their link
function
most commonly used ones are the linear
logistic and poisson regression models
to summarize the glm consists of three
components
the random component which specifies the
conditional distribution of the response
variable y
given the values of the explanatory
variables x
the probability distribution which
generates the observed variable y
the systematic component which specifies
the linear combination that explanatory
variables x are fit into by estimating b
in various ways this is also called the
linear predictor a linear combination of
parameter b and the explanatory variable
x finally the link function which
specifies the link between random and
systematic components link function
literally links the linear predictor and
the parameter for probability
distribution linearity means y is a
linear function of parameter b
regression is a powerful method for both
classification and regression problems
it can be used for continuous variables
or for categorical variables we would
like to predict
categorical prediction can yield weights
for observed variables and independent
observations this is a typical case for
anova or factor regression analysis
where we organize our observations into
groups based on some factor and find a
probability for each variable in
relationship to an effect of that factor
in classification the categorical value
is predicted based on the distribution
of probabilities modeled using a model
that was fit to our data
this model can learn from a given data
set and predict whether a new data set
can be classified a model like that is
called a classifier
for continuous variables regression
allows us to learn from data and predict
the next variable by learning about data
structures
this is often useful when we have
missing data in a set of continuous
variables or in time series data where
previous events can tell us something
about the future this type of a model is
called a regressor
that's all for today in our next session
we'll be speaking about network analysis